so Pamela Anderson can you tell us your
exciting news which I've had to keep a
secret for so long and I'm a terrible
secret keeper are you yeah I got to do
the last cover of Playboy wow that is
incredible
yeah well not the last cover but Pam is
marking a milestone as playboy changes
its longtime format she'll cover the
very last playboy with nudity how did
that come about like how did you get
approached for that I got a call from
Hef's attorney who said we don't want
anybody else there's nobody else could
you do the last cover of Playboy you
know the first was Marilyn Monroe
another iconic blonde now you the last
cover what does that mean to you well
Hef always told me he goes from Maryland
to you and he said I made this magazine
for a girl like you and you know I love
him so much he's such a sweetheart and
people have been asking me over the last
year would you ever posed for Playboy
again I'm like they're never gonna mean
I'm sure they're sick of me I mean had a
rough few years where I felt a little
insecure I was you know everyone's
getting older and then BOOM here they
call again so I made the most of it
Pam's done 14 Playboy covers her first
was way back in 1989 when she was just
22 years old times have changed but
Pam's two sons Brandon and Dylan who are
now 19 and 17 lawful mom taking it all
off one last time off of all the years
that they were teased and made fun of
and had a few fistfights
over there mom now I'm actually cool and
Brandon my oldest son
I actually asked his permission I said
have just called he wants me to do the
last cover play one heels mom's got to
do it because you got to do it that's so
crazy was so excited oh my god may
high-five me I can't believe all this
turn is past but I'm so glad that I was
a part of it